there's no alternative to this system
that happens to benefit me oh that's
convenient loquacious on the topic but
really it just means be nice
I don't mind FoxNews hating me I'm okay
with that I'm okay with that I want to
be the people's narcissist we have to
live beyond the dead model of our animal
selves ultimately the only thing that we
understand is love I think may know
we're pissed off I think they know they
just don't care when you see the Earth
from space you think oh my god
everything that ever happened happened
there we are all part of the one living
garment of God and there's no value in
judging other people aren't you bored on
you more bored than anyone and you've
been talking on year after year
listening to their lies their nonsense
then if this one gets in then it's that
one getting in but this problem
continues he's an English comedian actor
radio show host and author he's also a
public activist and campaigner he's
incorporated a lot of his controversial
public antics into his comedic material
he's wrestled bran and here are his top
ten naruse four she says truth is a
powerful us land you know we will go our
own personal troops now there are
certain principles they'll help align us
all just be true to your essential self
don't cover people over and a part of
that years be annoying tesco I think's
really important it's like you don't
like say when I was a kid it was all-out
apartheid and all that stuff is hella
and also woodruf tend to be sort of
angry about it and obviously I agree
with complete racial integration and
racial Kali but actually when I was at
home at night I won't actually I think
roof people who are blown apart article
on sleep you know didn't bother me
really like I say when I got ripped off
like a bus driver won't give me my fare
back or when there's an ATM charge of
350 I'm prepared and kill you know Oh an
apple change their charger you're like
you bastard so I have to keep changing
the charges for you know that stuff
really affects me and impacts me you
know so what I think we have to do is
recognize where in our own lives we've
been ripped off with a ripping us off
left them right you know like we've
recognized where those things are I
recognize that those things are not
necessary and when people tell you
they're there is no alternative look at
the people who are telling you that
there's
no alternative to this system that
happens to benefit me oh that's
convenient we've looked at all the
alternatives and the best one is me in a
big castle oh thanks well they'll stop
thinking debate over we see the you know
the Enlightenment realized state that
we'd like everybody to be in then we
have this kind of mess this quandary
that we're in right now so how do we
make those little bridging steps we make
you I think we attain it within
ourselves initially and we communicate
these ideas on a personal level
spirituality I can get as you've just
heard I can be very verbose and a
loquacious on the topic but really it
just means being nice it ain't hard just
be nice you meet a homeless person being
nice you get into a cab be nice to the
person don't see yourself as adversarial
then the revolution as always as already
occurred people fear Armageddon don't
make people fear the apocalypse don't
they but for some Armageddon has already
occurred the homeless people that walk
our streets live already in a
post-apocalyptic world Armageddon will
surely come for each of us around
personal Armageddon when each of us die
isn't it redundant whether everyone
simultaneously dies if each of us will
individually die regardless Armageddon
is coming so whilst these cataclysmic
principles apply on the individual level
people who think we might be able to
extend the human lifespan through
biotechnology merging issues over all
man but what I'm saying is is that what
we have to do is individually reach like
our own personal alignment we have to do
that the principles are all there you
know this the principles are already
there we achieved attachment through
meditation we no longer then then we are
no once we live once we can achieve
enlightenment and as once we put our
satisfaction beyond that our individual
needs we are no longer malleable by the
pre-existing system the system requires
us to be a selfish little consumerist
pods once we go on I bother about that
it's easier for me except being famous
now I know that's boring I've been rich
now I know that's boring loads of people
now I know that's boring took loads of
drugs now no that's boring so all that's
left is spiritual enlightenment oh I had
a really interesting thing the other day
about I don't know who this yogi was you
might be able to work out from there
from the anecdote no Bertrand Russell
the intellectual and surly CND
campaign for nuclear disarmament pioneer
was like through the end of his like I
think like real committed to that whole
CND deal and they visited by a yogi who
said to him look you know what does it
matter if we get rid of nuclear weapons
we are still the consciousness that
created nuclear weapons it will find
some other outlet what we need to
address is the inner space this
intention this attention the desire to
create that kind of technology as long
as we have that with we won't we won't
resolve the issue the nuclear weapon is
a symbol and emblem and expression of
that phenomena of that frequency so we
should address that and Bertrand Russell
said below that's just going to nuclear
weapons is a really significant issue I
have got time again your mystical bloody
Vedic approach to it let's get rid of
the weapons and but and I'll let you
know I think it's possible to agree with
both men in that instance and like that
all that you know the people that
criticize me people that adore me
they're responding really to themselves
they're responding to their own
consciousness they're responding to
their own reality and so I try to eat
now I know what my intention is I know
where my attention is and that is what
defines my life I try not to be to allow
my experience of reality to be too
diluted by other people's input I mean I
love the approval and I'm not so keen on
the condemnation but like also I look a
lot at the source I look a lot where it
comes from and like you know I don't
mind FoxNews hating me I'm okay with
that I'm okay with that you know that I
can't change who I am for Fox News what
would I become what would you say about
what Gandhi said that we have to become
the change we wish to see in the world I
think and as an aphorism it's a bloody
useful one because like my own personal
tendency to it can be to get well high
on the rhetoric and the chatting and the
showing off and then be a bit of a dog
in my private life do not mean my mummy
don't be
Chris [ __ ] about myself big enough
for that why everyone was waiting I
heard someone gonna point out this guy's
a prick
Frank tan Jesus what weight off someone
said it you bastards I'm trying my
hardest
yeah like well me my mate Matt used to
say like like you know it you saw talk
about socialism and sharing but in your
own actual life you're very intense like
this is why I'm working on I'm actually
viciously authoritative like controlling
man like I want I think I'm right I
think I'm right I'm on earth II sitting
around with em pricks cuz I know how
they think
I know how they work I've tried their
way of living and now I'm I am I want to
be the people's narcissist you know he
was the people's narcissistic I'm a
pretty reasonable guy Oh God
we trusted you um so yeah you're right
so again that's what I'm my main focus
is like you know what low so if
someone's like the other year I've been
a thing for give it up for comic relief
called give it up where I organized them
got together people raise money for
people and abstinence-based recovering
it was a big thing at Wembley it was
part of comic relief it was a big
shindig and all of that and it was a lot
of tension um and I thought it'd make me
feel really brilliant about it didn't as
much as when I just do normal things on
a one-to-one basis with people with
addiction issues and I think that's
because the frequency of that exchange
is somehow purer and more decent and
when I'm doing the showing off things of
course it has a function and a value but
it doesn't connect me in quite the same
way you know like so a lot of what I'm
doing this evening for example is I'm
showing off right it's set for the
moment where I talked about that Lady
Mary Hughes and I talked about we were
all right that was like we all felt
didn't we it was a little bit of a
different energy and it was a bit
sincere and wasn't that nice and I mean
sort of tried to do it in an English way
on that heartwarming moment
on Danny and kami so like you know yeah
so what um yeah I'm trying to work on
myself I'm just trying to do the best
that I can and yeah that Gandhi Maxim
that's a good one remember isn't it it's
like I love Joseph Campbell that geezer
says we were cause we don't have a
shared mythology we don't have a story
that brings us together but we do have
siculus saints we do have heroes people
we can look toward they've said like
that that we can build into our personal
belief system that's a nice one o'clock
be the change you want to be in the
world don't go my shiny mouth off and
then when it comes to the crunch belie
spend all your time doing coke and
banging brasses this is no good to
anyone is it I mean that colloquial
thing because of its linguistic kind of
potency
sorry it was dismissive but like yes
over you're right we are at the summit
of our evolution with 38% identical to
bananas DNA wise we're 67% identical to
earthworms DNA wise 98% identical to
chimpanzees DNA wise so we are what we
share together is infinitely greater
than what separates us to be at the
summit of our evolutionary possibility
we have to live beyond the dead model of
our animal selves of our urgent primal
selves we have to be at the apex of
evolution we have to be in the moment we
can't live in the dead animal self of
urge ease and acquisitiveness these
these are the things we have to
transcend a moment a moment this is what
I think is important to live in the apex
see like these old ideas about
individualism we've got to transcend
them the the distinctions between you
and I we know that they are an illusion
we share the same DNA there are
invisible energies that are true passing
between us the same way as this used to
have Wi-Fi before some tipped water on
it these invisible energies have to be
harnessed and accessed because it's the
only truth that matters as long as we
prioritize this material truth over
spiritual truth we will live in tyranny
because we are living in an illusion I
think awareness is all we must be aware
we must be aware of reality remember we
receive reality through a series of
filters the senses themselves are a
filtration system
remember the limitations of the eyes are
only able to see between ultraviolet
infrared light
the limitations of the ears and hearing
a certain frequency remember the
limitations of language placing
everything into a semantic syntactic
symbolic formula remember that reality
is too much for us to stack to stand
when we say we take it piecemeal in tiny
chunks to experience some to true
resonant reality we have to journey
within the only language that matters
truly is love that this Swami fella that
I know about in Mumbai told me of this
skill that once visited him a mother was
pregnant she was going to have another
door out when the kid was born she was
very very paraplegic double disabled and
little girl she would disappoint it's
ten years old who had certain
expectations of what this sister would
be like and when the sister was born all
paralyzed as are my expectations has not
been met I'm sad and she was resentful
for a while resentful with her parents
resentful with her sister resentful with
God but in time she recognized that if
he got frustrated or angry with the
little sister she didn't understand if
you spoke to the sister angrily she
didn't understand it mean nothing to her
but if you were loving to her if you
made her laugh her little face lit up
you know ultimately the only thing that
we understand is love we don't need any
of its permutations we're going to have
cultures we're going to have really
culture is our operating system and we
do need operating systems but we must
remember that our essence is love return
to it within yourself and express it to
all of us would be fine are you aware
about encouraging people lots of out
your disempowering them other people
will they've capitalized that will vote
you know I've made my opinions really
clear I think on this subject I'm it's
not like do if you want then if you want
but I don't think there's anyone who's
going to make any different spoil the
ballot if you want but let people
imagine that if there was a campaign to
spoil the ballot the people in
Westminster go oh my God look at they're
spoiling the ballots I think may know
we're pissed off I think they know they
just don't care they'll do whether they
can get away with you're destroying the
planet we've got 50 years till total
meltdown I'm going to scribble on my
ballot
now kindly hand over the reins of
civilization I don't think he's going to
cut it I don't think that's the language
they talk I don't think that's going to
change the debate do whatever you want
I'm just telling you what I'm gonna be
doing I'm gonna be amplifying people
that come together to create their own
organizations create their own
cooperatives that want to come together
to genuinely affect change and likely if
people come up with like old in the
minute I'll go Westminster and when I
get to Westminster my idea is that we
will disband it and we'll yeah and also
I think the concentrate power wherever
possible I think wherever power
concentrates it creates a [ __ ] you
know
and I like you know so like the
concentrate don't have it in one person
and I have to constantly remind myself
because like I say something and people
clap I think actually I should be in
charge and then I remember what fastener
question oh there's one
why did you stop what fall cuz I think
because I'm worse
I'm worse I'd get there I'd sort of sit
around in a green leather chair and not
feel like a bit of this expense account
you say build to be a chicken coop you
know I'd like by golly I won't want to
become one of them why do you think so
many people don't take the planetary
crisis seriously they're not climate
change deniers around lots we were going
out there saying it's all a myth it's an
exaggeration it's a left-wing plot the
planet is fine there's no warming
because if we start taking back
seriously the planet it bonds us all
together as one and it means that elites
cannot advance and it affects their
economic interest it's an economic issue
they need to be able to continue doing
their jobs which are about the
exploitation of the planet's resources
and if all of us start thinking in terms
hold on a minute we're all just on this
little bloody planet weapon like that
mad Carl Sagan thing what astronaut keys
I can't remember which one he was like
not one of the ones you'd remember about
7th to the moon by the anyone's well
right we go to the moon now who cares
hey I'm in the moon gear yes in it like
like but he said he goes when you see
the Earth from space you think oh my god
everything that's ever happened happened
there everything every war Adolphe
Hitler Jesus everything all the people
you've ever loved all the people you've
ever lost all the times you felt
embarrassed in your little tummy all the
time for all no she doesn't love me and
I love her all those little feelings on
that planet Shakespeare milk and all on
that planet there he said when you look
down at that beautiful planet and
realize oh my god in spite of what we
think we are literally connected we're
literally made of the same things
carbon-based life-forms breathing the
air in harmony with the planet it says
you look at that thing it makes you want
to grab a hot i'm politician by the
throat drag them up to space and they go
look look an idiot but like well could
you sustain the anger for that journey
hahahaha actually I've come to quite
liked you since we've been flowing in
the pod right I really get me so worked
up again tell me some of your beliefs
well I think I should have all right
there's that we got a spaceship I wish
we bought a monkey now look for me and
what I've started to started to try and
do is when I talk to someone right I
read a beautiful thing do you know that
riot Emmet Fox I think he's a Christian
riot he wrote a book called Sermon on
the Mount
you know lie so if I guess I probably
the first off always I guess it was
written and in it he said like when the
judge don't judge people like you still
have a sermon of the principles in
Christ Sermon on the Mount don't judge
people he said you know the judge not
lest you be judged right it's at any
time what that men is is that when
someone's behavior is unappealing to us
when we think they're obnoxious or
unattractive that in them the the Christ
in them is calling out to you to be
saved
calling out to you who are awake to be
saved there's no value in us judging
them or being negative like is only in
political figures or websites or later
or bigots obvious bigots Bill O'Reilly
Rush Limbaugh my country's Prime
Minister David Cameron like you saw
wanted you want to go you idiots
you're never like it's kind of been
falling into the trap there like that
I've sometimes wonder what would they do
if we just loved them if we just went
I'm gonna love you so hard how are they
gonna cope with that how are they going
to cope of the force of actual love and
to see them not as manifestations of
darkness or as evil but confused and
conflicted in that within them the
Christ in them is calling out calling
out to be saved it's said in this book
we are all part of the one living
garment of God and there's no value in
judging other people these little valves
they sort of like little cozy little
valves of recycling and Prius and like
you know turn up somewhere it stops us
reaching the pit point with a nice is
enough now stop voting stop attending
wake up be in reality now time to be in
reality now why vote we know it's not
gonna make any difference we know that
already
so a smoke impact at West Ham United
cheering them on and they lost the city
unless it's early Saturday okay well now
you're being facetious
well what facetiousness has asthma
value as seriousness I think you're
making a mistake of amis taking serious
and it's not good to solve world
problems by facetiousness that we're not
going to solve them with the current
system at least for seizures this is
funny sometimes yeah yeah sometimes
Jeremy so listen so this approach this
optimistically you've spent your old
career berating and haranguing
politicians and then when sub like me a
comedian goes yeah they're all worthless
what's the point engage of any of them
you said have a go at me because I'm not
poor anymore well I'm not having a go at
you about that I'm just asking why would
you take you seriously when you're so
unspecific you don't what to tell you
well firstly I don't mind if you take me
seriously I'm here just to draw
attention to a few ideas I just wanna
have a little bit of a laugh I'm saying
there are people with alternative ideas
that are far better qualified than I'm
and far better qualified more
importantly than the people that are
currently doing that job because they're
not attempting to solve these problems
they're not they're attempting to
placate the population their measures
that have currently been taken around
climate change are indifferent well not
so that yes it's possible as human
beings they're simply overwhelmed by the
scale of the problem not really well
possibly it might be there I mean but
that's what just semantics really
whether they're overwhelmed by it or
tacitly maintaining it because of
habitual like I mean like me I was is
what I noticed when I was in the houses
of parliament its decorated exactly the
same as Eton its decorated exactly same
as Oxford so a certain type of people
goes in and fix all this makes me
nervous and another type of people going
to go this is how it should be and I
think that's got to change now we can no
longer have erroneous duplicitous
systems held in place unless it's for
the Serb only systems that serve the
planet and serve the population of the
planet can be allowed to survive not
ones that serve elites be they a
political or corporate elite and this is
what's currently at me you don't really
believe that I completely believe it
don't look at me real I'm a fireside if
I put you me Ed Miliband was we went the
same private and primary schools poorest
I didn't he did but he then went to a
comprehensive school in North London
that's that's all well and good and but
what I'm saying is that within the
existing paradigm the change is not
dramatic enough not radical enough so
you can well understand public
disturbances and public dissatisfaction
when there are not genuine changes and
genuine alternatives being offered I say
when there is a genuine
alternative a genuine option then vote
for that but until then and bother why
pretend why be complicit in this
ridiculous illusion because by the time
somebody comes along you might think it
worth voting for it may be too late I
don't think so because the time is now
these movements are already occurring
it's happening everywhere we're in a
time where communication is
instantaneous and there are communities
all over the world
the Occupy movement made a difference in
even if only in that introduced to the
popular public lexicon the idea of the
1% versus the 99%
people for the first time in a
generation are aware of massive
corporate and economic exploitation
these things are not nonsense and these
subjects are not being addressed there
no one's doing anything about tax havens
no one's doing anything about their
political affiliations and financial
affiliations of the conservative pie so
until people start addressing things
that are actually real why wouldn't I be
facetious why would I take it seriously
why would I encourage a consist
constituency of young people that are
absolutely indifferent to vote why would
we aren't you bored aren't you more
bored than anyone and you've been
talking on year after year listening to
their lies their nonsense then if this
one gets in then it's that one getting
but this problem continues why are we
going to continue to contribute to this
facade I'm surprised you can be
facetious when you're that angry about
it yeah I'm angry I am angry because for
me it's real because for me it's not
just some peripheral thing I turn up
once in a while to a church fight for
for me this is what I come from this is
what I care about do you see any huh
remember that yeah totally there's going
to be a revolution it's totally going to
happen I think not Natalie I ain't got a
flicker of doubt this is the end this is
time to wake up I remember I see you in
that program where you look at your
ancestors and you saw that while your
grandmother
we're at to brass herself or I got over
by the aristocrats who ran a gaff you
cried because you knew that it was
unfair and unjust and that was what was
that a century ago that's happening to
people now I just come from a woman
who's being treated like that
I just been talking to a woman today
who's being treated like that so if if
we can engage that feeling instead of
some moment of lachrymose sentimentality
trotted out on the TV for people to pour
over emotional porn if we can engage
that feeling and change things why
wouldn't we
I use that naive why is that not my
right because I'm an actor I mean I I've
taken the right I don't need the right
from you I don't need the right from
anybody
I'm taking it thank you so much for
watching we make this video because
Marcus Morgan access to and if you have
anyone that you would like us to feature
please leave a comment below I also love
to know which of Russell Brand's top 10
rules meant the most to you leave it in
the comments we'll join a discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and we'll see you soon